we tend to get very attached to plan A's
we'll get married move into a house near
the park work in financial services
pivot into philanthropy and then end up
in a Cottage By the Sea painting and
looking after our grandchildren or we'll
become a famous actor play in a
selection of thoughtful dramas about the
inner life and in time move into
production or perhaps mentorship and
then life laughs and we get cancer or a
fired or say the wrong thing or declare
bankruptcy or get tinitus or go bipolar
there are around 78 major organs in the
body and each one of them can go
spectacularly wrong in hugely fluid and
Rapid ways we're surrounded by millions
of people whose aspirations are actively
or passively in conflict with our own we
are acutely fragile bundles of nerves
and neurons a drift in a sharp edged
random Universe the chances of something
going wrong are enormous and they will
what we therefore need as much as an
education in realizing some of our
dreams is robust tutorship in making up
Alternatives what might we do when the
first marriage blows up when the Scandal
hits when our liver packs up when our
eyesight goes when three best friends
die we should keep our grasp on all plan
A's tentative and light this is the
person we're married to for now this is
the house we're living in at the moment
this is our reputation
at this point in time nothing is
guaranteed but then fortunately nor are
our requirements for survival as fixed
as we may have believed we are creatures
who when we need to will accept easily
enough that the moment has come to die
and from this underused realistic muscle
flows a much underappreciated capacity
to take difficult thoughts on board we
assumed that we'd always have two legs
now we're going to have to make do with
one we thought we'd always be able to
speak
now we need to type out our intentions
on a computer we imagined we'd never be
single again now we're cooking for one
we thought they'd die first now we're
arranging their funeral the only
prediction we can rely on is that life
will with ceaseless Ingenuity always
outrun our finest predictions